you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now yeah
Southwestern Utah part of that winter
storm warning here in southern Nevada
Lincoln County's got a winter weather
advisory and while there is some
sunshine way out to the West a lot of us
still under cloud cover and 59 degrees
is as far as well actually that's
actually down a degree from about an
hour ago but we wanted to check in on
your neighborhood let's see what's going
on there is a 64 at the Air Force Base
but the mid 50s for Summerlin how about
the low 40s up at Kyle Canyon definitely
going to be a mix of rain and snow up in
the higher elevations we could see some
sprinkles here maybe even a snowflake up
in the higher elevations we're not
talking about any accumulation of
anything though here's that Caliente
with 48 you're part of the winter
weather advisory Cedar City part of the
winter storm warning Mesquite you're
hanging at 66 and out in Death Valley
hanging on to a 74. so our daytime high
that was actually at midnight okay so
the temperature has been sliding our
current temperatures will know so far
we're probably going to be in the 40s
but the time we get to midnight tonight
we're not going to see anything around a
normal high not in the next eight days
or so that is for sure normal low would
be 53. so yes A possibility of rain
mixed with snow generally over the
higher elevation so this front is
marching out to the east the cold air
spilling down behind it that's why
temperatures are going to drop even more
tomorrow now for your family and friends
Across the Nation let's see what we got
going on out here on some scattered
showers across the Ohio Valley and that
is really about it we're just kind of
waiting for this storm to turn into a
lot more snow for northern Utah and move
on into the Rockies here's your most
accurate eight-day forecast now very
windy today again the high already
happened only 55 for the high tomorrow
and some neighborhoods are going to dip
down to the upper 30s certainly if not
this morning or tomorrow morning then
into Friday morning we'll start to see
little bit of a break 60 for Friday
Saturday partly cloudy and 66 then
another round of wind comes in and of
course we're moving our clocks back on
Sunday morning Heather